[Musique]
la culture en Suède est très importante si
les gens vous disent de vous aligner, vous vous
alignez donc c'est plus lui-même réglementé Je pense que
tous ceux qui avaient la possibilité de travailler
à domicile l'ont fait, tous ceux qui avaient la
possibilité d'éviter les
transports en commun  c'est je pense qu'au
début beaucoup de gens pointent
du doigt je pense que c'est gentil mais peut-être
maintenant ils examinent tous le
fait que vous ne pouvez pas éviter le virus je veux
dire bien sûr que vous devez le contenir pour
pouvoir faire face  avec ça, mais je veux dire ce qui
se passe maintenant quand ils s'ouvrent dans d'
autres pays et que les gens
viennent de rester à la maison et que le virus est toujours
là en soi, il va sortir une
deuxième vague et puis ils doivent
peut-être se refermer
Je pense que tout le monde saura que je ne
sais pas dans six mois dans un an à partir de maintenant
qui a fait l'écrivain qui n'a pas fait la
bonne chose
[Musique]
notre position de président que ce n'est que de
la panique savons-nous si nos autorités ont dit
et fait '  Pour trouver que tout est abrogé, nous
savons particulièrement que nous devons être paniqués,
ils ne contrôlent pas la situation quant à moi comme
pour toutes les personnes qui peuvent rester à la maison, nous restons à la
maison et je ne vais au magasin que pour acheter de la
nourriture et je pense que la plupart des Biélorusses se soucient
de rien quand  t'entends dix fois par jour
ce virus ce n'est pas dangereux tu ne
penses pas à la voiture
[Musique]